Awesome.
Uh thank you for joining. I this is
welcome to my lightning talk and today
as mentioned I'll talk about evals. Um
so I want to start with a thought. I
think at some point in life we we've all
met someone when we ask them a question
they give the right answer but when you
kind of poke for the explanation you
sort of guess you sort of see that they
were either guessing the answer you know
they have maybe memorized it or they
were just copying from somewhere right
and that's not like trust is not the
issue that's another topic right but the
idea is that you cannot predict if you
ask them the question again if you will
get the same right answer also if you
want to give them feedback back and try
and improve their answer. There's no
underlying skill to give feedback on.
And the same idea goes with agents which
were graded on brittle outcome focused
benchmarks.
So that brings me to my uh motivation
for today which is agent evaluation
today is rooted in very narrow outcome
only uh scoring which essentially hides
explanability and reliability. So if you
have an agent, it achieves 80% success
on a benchmark. That doesn't tell you
much, right? That doesn't tell you why
it worked 80% of the time. It doesn't
tell you why it failed the other 20% of
the time. It also does not tell you how
do you improve that 80% number to be 90
95 and closer to 100. And then lastly,
it doesn't tell you that if you bring
that agent to your infrastructure, to
your environment, will the results also
follow? Right? And if you change things
in your infrastructure, what would
really happen? Will it stay stable or
not? At least not without uh some
significant cost in brute forcing.
So let's look at an example just to get
the point across, right? U so on the
left side we see some code which might
be vulnerable. If this was a benchmark,
you put uh you know uh an agent might
output something that looks like this.
Uh and if you only care about the
outcome, you're like, okay, it found
SQL. Uh so this is a pass, right? We
move on. But if you were to look at the
trace of the agent, you might see that
it followed very shallow huristics to
get to this answer, right? But what the
agent did not do was it did not trace
the taint flowing into the method. It
did not check for exploitability, right?
Was this uh data actually sanitized
downstream? It also did not come up with
any evidence of how it found the bug,
right? Other than the pattern matching
that it did. And that is where the
problem is, right? The problem is that
the agent did a very superficial
analysis and it did not reason through
the taint flow to get to the bottom of
the bug and it did not share with you
the different scenarios in which it
could be exploited. So this information
is very critical especially for security
because I think most of us will agree
security is not an isolated task right
it is almost always a workflow and for
the most part it is something that
closes in a loop right you find a bug
you exploit it you want to patch it and
then you want to validate that the bug
and all of its variants do not exist in
your environment anymore so let's go
back to the SQL example we saw right if
we only cared about the outcome of that
particular stage in which case it would
be like the fine stage. We would say
okay this is a success but does that
mean it's an end toend success? Maybe
not because the agent did not carry the
context over right it did not tell you
the different exploit scenarios the
evidence and what it might end up doing
is that we might end up creating
incomplete or incorrect patches for this
particular bug. So our endto-end
workflow just breaks right and we do not
get the success for the full workflow we
only got it for one stage. Um on the
other hand if the agent did pass that
information on then we would have had a
higher chances of end toend workflow
success. So that's why we believe
looking at agents capabilities is just
as important. So things like reasoning
memory planning uh over and above
looking at just the outcome
and to solve for that we built clasp. So
clasp is a capabilitycentric
evaluation framework. The idea is very
simple. It gives you six rubrics for six
different agentic capabilities. Uh and
the idea is that if the agent has a very
brittle u capability then you get a
lower score. If it has a very adaptive
execution of the same capability you get
a higher score. And what this does is
the the fra the framework pushes you to
ask the question how did we achieve this
success over and above did we achieve
this success? Um, and if you look at
this six, you might be asking, but do
all of them matter for all of the
security different tasks? And that's a
question I also wanted to answer. So, we
applied clasp to some existing agents.
And we found that there are indeed some
capabilities that matter more for some
specific security task than others. So,
I'll give you a fun example. We found
that for very enumerationheavy tasks, so
like any recon agent, breadth matter
much more than depth. So any any agent
that uh planned really well which tools
to use and then use those tools ex uh
you know uh extensively to enumerate
everything it can about a target. It had
a better outcome success than agents
that reasoned about what they found and
just keep going deep for such an
enumerative task. So that is one of the
key uh highlights we saw. And then
there's others as well which uh which
are there in our paper. You can check it
out and see for yourself. But why we did
this was to just get a skill attribution
for each security step. Um and this
knowledge can really really help in
answering the question hey I have an
agent I want to improve it but I don't
know where to start. So you know if you
know what kind of agent it is you know
which capabilities you should start
with. It gives you a good starting point
from that perspective. And the rubrics I
showed in the previous slide tell you
how to get better.
So let's bring all all of that together
and let's help you use clasp, right? How
can you use it in practice? It's a
three-step approach. First,
observability. Bake it into your
workflows. Make sure you have access to
everything your agent touches. You know,
be it the context retrieved, be it the
reasoning trace, be it the tool calls it
made, etc., etc. Second, you evaluate
the agent. And I'll come back to
evaluation in a second. From the
evaluation, you might find ways to
improve your agent. And then like I
said, use the uh the table I showed
before as a good starting point on what
to improve. And now let's come back to
evaluation, right? Evaluation can happen
in two ways. The first one which is like
a easier lift is build an LLM as a judge
pipeline. Give it the class rubric. give
it your agent's trace and say great you
know tell me how am I doing for planning
tell me how my agent is doing for tool
call and if you get a two you know what
to do using our rubrics to get to a four
and then rerun again and see if that
also improves improves your outcome the
other way to evaluate which is uh
slightly more heavier lift is to build
test scenarios so this idea is actually
taken from something called as evidence-
centered benchmark design so you build
test scenarios for each of the
capabilities at varying complexities
uh and I'll give you an example for tool
use for uh a more lower score would be
an agent that has a default tools that
it always go through goes through those
tools maybe in the same order it does
not get a lot of feedback from the
environment and just statically goes and
executes them. Uh whereas a more higher
score would be it has it dynamically
chooses the tool it listens to the
environmental feedback it listens to the
errors it chains the tools together and
then creates uh its exploit flow or
whatever it's trying to get at. Um but
regardless of which evaluation technique
you choose the idea is you get a number
back you try and understand where you
stand and then you have a clear path on
how to move forward uh using our
rubrics.
That's it from my side. Just wrapping
up. Uh don't evaluate on isolated narrow
outcomes. Dig deeper into the how of
these agents and a capability centric um
grading system like class can help you
create more reliable, more explainable
and more parsimony aware systems.
Uh thank you so much for listening to
me. This is the full paper if someone's
interested. Uh this was my personal
work, nothing related to Airbnb. And uh
this 10-minute uh presentation was just
a very slight uh more industry forward
uh takeaway from my paper. But if you're
interested, that's my academic paper and
that's my LinkedIn. Thank you.
>> Questions?
Uh so I I love the like the table of owl
of clasp. It's like so so applicable in
operationalizing it. You kind of said
like yeah you can use all of them as a
judge to start classifying these things.
Uh you do you feel like you have a set
of prompts or a way of structuring the
data that maybe is described in the
paper but like we should open source or
get get started on?
>> Yes. So
>> mic please. Sorry.
>> Sorry. Yes. So we do want to also try
and do a benchmark. So if you read the
paper, we do mention like a blueprint of
the benchmark that we're working on and
that's the more like test scenario. So
it is you know easily available. You
don't even have to create an NLM as a
judge because we both know that's not
the perfect way to do it. You know it's
a lighter lift. Sure. Uh but the idea
would be then you just run your agent on
that benchmark and that benchmark will
not just looking at the outcome it will
also look at the actual behavioral
trail. it will see what your reasoning
trace was whether you followed you know
a more brittle approach or a more
adaptive and autonomous approach where
you actually reflected on what you were
doing you perceived the environmental
signals and then went to the next stage
so we are working on the benchmark uh
and then for uh LM that's a good point
we I do have it maybe I should look into
open sourcing it so yeah yeah thank you
>> any anything to save the rest of us time
>> uh any other questions
all All right. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.